wie würde sich ihr leben verändern wenn
ihr eine gruppe von menschen stehen und
dann einfach euer handy herausziehen und
ist so drehten basketball ja
wahrscheinlich gar nicht wenn ihr das
coole waffen wollt dann sollte das eher
aussehen wie bei drehen weil das ist
richtig geil geil transition er kennt
wahrscheinlich alle für meine selbst
experimente bei denen man wirklich
krasse sachen ja mit denen man
grundlegend sein leben ändern kann das
komplette gegenteil dazu ist dieses
format bei dem ich einfach nur die
polizisten talente überhaupt klären und
alle fans lustig oder denken wir nur hat
der typ zu viel zeit und ja ich habe
viel zu viel zeit hier werde ich sachen
lernen wie zum beispiel jonglieren oder
die zahnbürste um seinen finger drehen
fühle dass ich das schon kann ich weiß
auch nicht warum let's go also heute ist
der erste tag und um zu demonstrieren
wie schwer das ganze was wir vorhaben
eigentlich ist nimmt mal euer handy in
die hand legt es auf euren finger und
versucht das ganze zu drehen
also ihr seht es ist echt ultra
schwierig das überhaupt irgendwo drin
und ich frag mich wie der kerl im video
gibt es ein video auf mehrere tipps wie
man das am besten umsetzen kann einen
tipp davon ist ein großes pendel zu
haben das haben wir aber der
wahrscheinlich wichtigste ist dass man
nicht auf seiner fingerspitze anfängt
sondern erstmal auf seinem auf seine
fingerabdruck gegen das damals einfach
eine größere fläche hat und das nicht so
schwer ist handy dann zu balancieren und
es ist auch wichtig seine hand flach zu
halten dass man sein handy direkt wieder
auffahren kann wenn runterfällt ab und
po runterfallen benutzt auf jeden fall
will weil das handy wird euch echt oft
darunter fallen und es wird einfach
kaputt gehen ich habe deswegen diese
geile hülle und diesem film perfekte von
30 schild wenn ihr euer handy auch
schützen möchtest dann findet ihr über
den link in der video beschreibung zur
rheinschiene webseite da gibt es bis zu
einem drittel 12 noch bis zu 60 prozent
rabatt und mit dem coach tommy friday
noch mal zehn prozent obendrauf und da
ich mich mit diesem geräusch alle drei
sekunden wahrscheinlich bei meinen
nachbarn extrem unbeliebt machen würde
werde ich wohl doch lieber das sofa auch
unterlegen auch wenn die würde das
aushalten würde beginnen damit den
ersten versuchen hand halten mit finger
auf den fingerabdruck drauf und dann
wird mehr energie steht halt doch
leichter ok also jetzt halb drei langsam
fertig auch das ding mal zu drehen
meistens immer einmal grad eben sogar
zweimal ohne dass es wunder fällt es ist
auf jeden fall gut dass ich langsam
mahlen
dass ich langsam ein gefühl dafür kriegt
wie man das handy in der hand hält und
ich nicht direkt beim ersten versuch
unterwirft ich muss aber auch sagen dass
ich mehrere stunden am tag trainiert und
das mir deswegen tatsächlich so dumm wie
es klingt auch meine hand betont
insbesondere der finger auch wenn ich
wirklich fortschritte mache es dauert
nicht ewig und ist ich weiß nicht wie
ich das in einer woche lernen soll ich
mein guckt euch an er ist ein gott und
ich ein bloßes sterblicher es gibt viele
spaßige oder streben seine fähigkeiten
die man erlernen kann seine sprachen
instrumente computerprogramme oder das
tanzen bei allen verläuft die motivation
skore ungefähr gleich beflügelt von den
großartigen leistungen derjenigen die
die fähigkeit bereits gemeistert haben
stürzt man sich auf den lernprozess
dabei wird der wille zu lernen getragen
von der motivation und von der
begeisterung ab 9
das macht aber nach kürzester zeit ab
und diejenigen die ihre fehlende
motivation nicht mehr selbstdisziplin
entgegenkommen die geben meistens recht
schnell auf nur diejenigen
die sich mit ihrer eigenen willenskraft
über diesen hügel befördern können
kommen in den genuss das handwerk so gut
zu beherrschen das ist richtig spaß
macht oder davon sogar andere menschen
damit begeistern kann
zum ersten mal eine gitarre in die hand
zu nehmen und mit ihr geräusche zu
erzeugen macht spaß ein extrem guter
gitarrist zu sein der auch in eine bühne
sein publikum verzaubert das macht mir
ein loch mehr spaß aber auf dem weg
dahin zum tausendsten mal den gleichen
langweiligen clip zu üben dass das macht
keinen spaß und genau so fühle ich mich
jetzt gerade wie ich seit drei tagen
nichts anderes mache jeden tag ein paar
stunden diesen move hier natürlich lohnt
alter da hat sich die will ja mal sowas
von gelohnt tag fünf mal angebrochen
ich fühle mich jetzt langsam sicherheit
genug das handy nicht mehr auf meinem
fingerabdruck drehen zu lassen sondern
mal dass mit der fingerspitze zu
probieren let's go das klappt ja schon
gehabt ja schon mal super nicht schlecht
ich glaube ich war besser als ich noch
auf einen fingerabdruck gedreht habe das
kann ich nämlich mittlerweile echt
ziemlich gut aber auch das ist so eine
sache wo man am anfang erstmal ein
bisschen schlechter werden muss um
langfristig besser zu werden wenn ihr
versteht was ich meine
[Musik]
wie langsam fängt an spaß zu machen dass
mit dem finger funktioniert tatsächlich
relativ gut mittlerweile heute ist der
siebte tag ist es jetzt einige wochen
vergangen seitdem ich angefangen hat
dieses geld zu lernen obwohl der selbst
schon ziemlich nice war bin ich damit
noch nicht 100 prozent zufrieden
also ich merke natürlich will ich immer
besser werde langsam wie die versuche
immer stabiler werden und auch immer
länger gehen aber ich würde einfach
gerne das noch länger können ich bin
noch nicht ganz happy damit mein ziel
ist es dass herr nehmendes ist drei
sekunden auf den fingern zu balancieren
und das war gerade mal eine ok zehnter
tag ist wird immer besser
ich muss ein bisschen flex und jetzt
hier fällt immer noch manchmal runter
aber die versuche die gehen schon viel
viel länger
der war wirklich stark also ihr seht
schon es wird bei mir ist aufgefallen
dass man muss dann quasi wenn sich der
rotation mittelpunkt vom handy ein
bisschen weiter weg vom finger schiebt
einen finger ruckartig runter rutschen
lassen damit man sich mit sie sollen
wirklich drunter tag mittlerweile kann
gut wie lang war das alter habe ich mich
bedankt das handy immer noch nicht
gefolgt ist ich glaube nicht ein skate
den ich noch nicht beherrsche wäre jetzt
quasi das handy zu drehen und
gleichzeitig noch mit der anderen hand
zu an zu finden wie der im video aber
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen das werde
ich in der kurzen zeit nicht schaffen
ich hab auch in den kommentaren gelesen
dass derjenige wie gesagt hat dass er
dafür ein ganzes jahr gebraucht hat bis
er dieses wissens käse drauf hatte dass
er dazu an schubsen konnte ich probier
es aber trotzdem
der tag der wahrheit ist gekommen heute
stellt sich heraus ob sich die ganze
harte arbeit das war wirklich es war so
viel unnötige dumme arbeit wie viel zeit
habe es ist echt unfalls war heute wer
sich schon ob sich das alles gelohnt
habe ich habe ich extra schick gemacht
hier ist das objekt mit dem der rekord
von drei sekunden erreicht werden soll
let's go nicht schlecht aber auf jeden
fall keine zwei sekunden
der war ich weiß nicht vielleicht weil
es mir leider nicht
oh mein gott
der war stark der war
o
[Musik]
wenn die was gut ist und könnt euch eine
höhle er ist jetzt was sie gerade tun
aushalten und mal ehrlich leute das ist
echt einiges ist das handy einfach
tausend mal runter gefallen und es hat
einmal keinen einzigen kratzer genauso
wichtig natürlich der bildschirm schwarz
wie der bildschirm kaputt ist ja die
jungs von reiner schick haben
verschiedene designs und bis dienstag
gibt es dann auf 60 prozent rabatt drauf
und nur für euch nochmal zehn prozent
obendrauf mit dem connery friday den
link findet ihr ein video beschreibung
und werde mich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchtet dann abonniert diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]